en este hospital de activa one al oeste
de senegal al menos 11 recién nacidos
murieron como consecuencia de un
incendio ocurrido el miércoles
me informaron del incendio pero no le
dije a mi hija hasta que despertó el
jueves le dije y nos abrazamos y
nos solidarizamos con su dolor estas
mujeres todavía tenían la esperanza de
que su recién nacido todavía estuviese
vivo senegal está de luto y tenemos que
aceptarlo
la película se adapta a las figuras de
la política se presentaron al lugar
durante la noche y en 'twitter' el
presidente del país macky sall expresó
su profunda compasión me acabo de
enterar con dolor y consternación del
fallecimiento de 11 recién nacidos en el
incendio ocurrió en el departamento de
neonatología del hospital de tivo one a
sus madres y sus familias expresó mi más
sentido pésame pero la tragedia no
impide la exasperación del país porque
el siniestro se suma a varios dramas
recientes ocurridos en hospitales
senegaleses que ponen al descubierto las
deficiencias en el sistema de salud
publicó a principios de abril una mujer
en labores de parto murió después de
esperar por más de 20 horas una cesárea
en abril de 2021 en langer al norte del
país otro incendio en una sala de
materia edad causó la muerte de cuatro
infantes tragedias que han despertado
una ola de indignación la oposición ha
pedido que se revele todo sobre esta
tragedia y anunciaron una suspensión de
las actividades políticas por los
próximos tres días